One, two. From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. And I'm standing at the corner of Diversey and Broadway in Chicago. As I record this, it's just a few minutes after 3 o'clock on a weekday afternoon here in Chicago. And the people are everywhere, even though it's still the middle of the workday.
一、二。这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台和国际公共广播电台联合播出的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。此时我正站在芝加哥迪弗西大道和百老汇大道的交汇处。当我录制这段节目时，芝加哥正值平日下午三点刚过。尽管还是工作时间，但到处都是人。
In the bread shop just off the corner, I stuck my head in, and there are people at the tables. Some of them are just sitting there reading books. I saw two guys speaking Spanish walk in and find their friend, who greeted them in Spanish. And they headed out.
拐角处的面包店里，我探头进去看了看，桌边坐满了人。有些人只是坐在那里看书。我看见两个讲西班牙语的人走进去找他们的朋友，朋友用西班牙语问候了他们。然后他们就离开了。
A guy in a goatee and a knit cap just walked by wearing a pair of professional grade stereo headphones around his neck, talking to his buddy. In the last 10 minutes, I've seen three different people, all men, wearing professional grade stereo headphones just on the street. I didn't even know this was a trend.
一个留着山羊胡、戴着针织帽的男人刚刚走过，脖子上挂着一副专业级立体声耳机，正和他朋友聊天。在过去的十分钟里，我已经在街上看到了三个不同的人，全是男的，都戴着专业级立体声耳机。我甚至都不知道这成了一种潮流。
How you doing?
你好吗？
A guy in a suit's staring at me. In the hours when most of us are at work or at school, there is a whole life going on out here, outside, an alternate world. I would say it's a world with its own rules, but its rules are actually a lot like the rules of Saturday, except taking place during the week and different people taking part. This is the secret world of daytime. Guy just ran the red light. Can't get his plates.
一个穿西装的男人正盯着我看。在我们大多数人都在上班或上学的这段时间里，这里却有着另一种完整的生活，外面的世界，一个平行的世界。我会说这是一个有着自己规则的世界，但它的规则其实和周六很像，只不过发生在工作日，而且参与的人不同。这就是白天的秘密世界。刚才那家伙闯红灯了，没看清他的车牌。
Well, back in the studio now. Today, we take a little tour of the secret life of daytime with five separate stories. Act One, Why Aren't You at Work?, in which one intrepid reporter has a little chat with some of those people who are on the street at 3:00. Act Two, In a World Full of Soybeans, the Men Turn to Love, the surprising story of how people kill time at one Lincoln, Nebraska, grain elevator. Act Three, The Geography of Childhood, a tale of the secret places that children go during the day in one town in Vermont. Act Four, Invisible Man. A postman explains how it is that he can be so much a part of the scenery that people commit crimes in front of him. Crimes on quiet, daytime streets, as if he is not there. Act Five, $82.50 a Day, writer Mona Simpson reads from her forthcoming novel about the daytime life of Filipino nannies during the hours in which they run the lovely homes of certain Los Angeles neighborhoods. Stay with us.
好了，回到演播室。今天，我们将通过五个独立的故事带大家参观一下白天的秘密生活。第一幕，《你为什么没去上班？》，一位勇敢的记者与几位下午三点出现在街头的人聊了聊。第二幕，《在充满大豆的世界里，男人们转向了爱情》，讲述了内布拉斯加州林肯市一家谷物仓库的人们是如何打发时间的惊人故事。第三幕，《童年的地理学》，讲述了佛蒙特州一个小镇的孩子们白天去的秘密场所。第四幕，《隐形人》，一位邮递员解释了他是如何完全融入背景，以至于人们在他面前犯罪——在安静的白昼街道上犯罪，仿佛他不存在一样。第五幕，《每天82.5美元》，作家莫娜·辛普森朗读她即将出版的小说片段，讲述了菲律宾保姆在照看洛杉矶某些社区豪宅期间的白天生活。请继续收听。
Act One, Why Aren't You at Work?
第一幕，《你为什么没去上班？》
Let's begin with a few simple answers to a few simple questions. All those people you see in the middle of the day when you run out to a doctor's appointment-- you see them in coffee shops and bookstores in most cities and suburbs-- who are they? Why are they not at work? Investigative reporter George Gurley tackled these tough questions on a scenic little island that we like to call Manhattan.
让我们从几个简单问题的几个简单答案开始。当你跑去赴医生预约时，在白天看到的那些人——你在大多数城市和郊区的咖啡馆和书店里都能见到他们——他们是谁？为什么没去上班？调查记者乔治·格利在一个我们喜欢称之为曼哈顿的风景优美的小岛上，处理了这些棘手的问题。
Hello, America. I did what we all are tempted to do. On four afternoons, I approached these people and ask them why they weren't at work and what exactly were they doing.
你好，美国。我做了我们大家都想做的事。在四个下午，我走近这些人，问他们为什么没去上班，以及他们到底在做什么。
We haven't seen each other in about a week and a half. So we thought, let's get a bite to eat, and it's a beautiful day out, so we'll come to the park.
我们已经有一个半星期没见面了。所以我们想，吃点东西吧，外面天气很好，我们就来公园了。
Are you retired, are you still working?
你是退休了，还是还在工作？
I'm semi-retired. I'm old enough to collect social security. But I still work a few days a week. Of course, next question is, what kind of work do you do? Don't tell my cat. I'm a furrier.
我半退休了。我已经到了领取社会保障金的年龄。但我仍然每周工作几天。当然，下一个问题是，我做什么工作？别告诉我猫。我是皮草商。
Do you think that you've had a productive day today?
你觉得你今天过得充实吗？
I got showered.
我洗了个澡。
What are you doing right now? Why aren't you at work?
你现在在做什么？为什么没去上班？
I'm here on a business trip.
我来这里出差。
Oh, OK. There we go.
哦，好的。原来如此。
So I sort of am at work.
所以我算是在工作吧。
So you're working. Right.
所以你在工作。对。
As it turns out, a lot of these people actually have jobs, the kind of jobs where they set their own hours or work nights or weekends. They're actors, sculptors, bartenders. I met one guy who takes care of primates and other mammals at the Bronx Zoo, who has Tuesdays and Wednesdays off. Released from his cage, he spends those afternoons drinking screwdrivers, guilt-free.
事实证明，这些人中很多其实有工作，那种可以自己安排时间，或者在晚上或周末工作的工作。他们是演员、雕塑家、调酒师。我遇到一个人，他在布朗克斯动物园照看灵长类动物和其他哺乳动物，周二和周三休息。被从“笼子”里放出来后，他把那些下午花在无罪恶感地喝螺丝起子鸡尾酒上。
Daytime hours are different if you're not working. They're about going with the flow, one thing leading to another. Alana Canty, a 50-year-old English tutor from New Jersey, was in Central Park purely by coincidence.
如果你不工作，白天的时光就不同了。那关于顺其自然，一件事引出另一件事。艾拉娜·坎蒂，一位来自新泽西的50岁英语导师，纯粹是偶然来到了中央公园。
I was an extra on a TV show, which I got because-- I suffer from depression, and I don't actively pursue stuff like that. But I have a friend staying at my house. And he signed up with an agency. And they called last night, and I took the call. And I said, "Do you need any women?" He said, "Sure." OK.
我曾在一部电视剧里当临时演员，那是——因为我患有抑郁症，不会主动去追求这类工作。但我有个朋友住在我家，他向一家经纪公司报了名。他们昨晚打来电话，我接了，我说：“你们需要女人吗？”他说：“当然。”好吧。
So I had to show up at 8 o'clock at the boathouse. And it was a taping of a scene from the program Once and Again, I think. And basically, we got $41 for standing in a crowd. So here I am having a lovely day in New York, all because my friend went to an extra agency.
所以我得在8点赶到船屋。那是电视剧《再续前缘》的一场戏拍摄。基本上，我们就站在人群里，拿到了41美元。所以我在这里度过了美好的一天，全是因为我朋友去了一家临时演员经纪公司。
It's been-- The most productive I've done today is put my check in the bank.
这是——我今天最有成效的事情就是把支票存进银行。
This is Jonathan Bradley, a bearded 25-year-old. I met him at the Angelica, a theater in SoHo that shows mostly independent films. It was around 3 o'clock, and a dozen or so people were waiting for their film to be announced or just hanging out. Inside the theater cafe, Jonathan was reading Village Voice after seeing his movie, killing some time before his customer service gig at a website. I asked him if there was anything else he could have achieved today.
这位是乔纳森·布拉德利，一位蓄着胡须的25岁小伙子。我是在苏荷区的安吉丽卡剧院见到他的，那里主要放映独立电影。当时大约是下午3点，十几个人在等电影开场或只是闲逛。在剧院咖啡馆里，乔纳森在看《乡村之音》，他在看完电影后，在去网站做客服工作前打发时间。我问他今天还能完成别的事情吗。
The only thing I could have done today was maybe, if I was home, I could've made some phone calls for our meditation group. I'm in a Buddhist group, and we're looking for a space. So if I was at home this morning, I could've made some phone calls on that.
我今天唯一能做的事可能就是，如果我在家，我可以给我们冥想小组打些电话。我参加了一个佛教小组，我们正在找场地。所以如果我今天早上在家，我就能打那些电话。
What would Buddha say about your day so far?
佛祖会怎么评价你今天过得如何？
That's a difficult question to answer because Buddhism is rarely a thing that is dogmatic like that, that says, you should perform this way. But I think just "use the time wisely" might be a good general statement.
这是个很难回答的问题，因为佛教很少有那种教条式的东西说你必须怎么做。但我认为“明智地利用时间”可能是一个好的总结。
Across the cafe was Randy Maggiore, a long-haired 34-year-old actor. He just picked up some head shots and now is spending some free time visiting a friend. But he didn't feel like he was wasting time. For an actor, apparently, simply being awake to the world counts as work.
咖啡馆对面是兰迪·马焦雷，一位长发飘飘的34岁演员。他刚取了一些演员照，现在正花些空闲时间拜访朋友。但他并不觉得自己在浪费时间。对于演员来说，显然，仅仅是对世界保持清醒就算作是工作。
It's sort of like my errands are, for me, part of my education because being out on the street and walking around and seeing new things and seeing people, I try to be as observant as I possibly can in regard to what I see. As an actor, it's like I constantly study character in people. So every day, right outside my door is an experience, I think, something to learn.
对我来说，跑腿就像是教育的一部分，因为走在街上，四处逛逛，观察新事物，观察人，我努力尽可能观察我所见的一切。作为演员，就像我一直在研究人们的性格。所以每一天，就在我家门外，都是一种体验，我觉得，是某种可以学习的东西。
Loafing? That's so colloquial. Loafing.
游手好闲？这个词太口语化了。游手好闲。
This is Howard Moneth. He told me he does a little day trading, inherited some money. He was sitting on a bench and drinking a latte outside a Mott Street art gallery he helps run. Wearing a floppy blue hat and shades, he'd been catching rays there for 45 minutes and looked high on life, nearly beatific.
这是霍华德·莫内斯。他告诉我他做点日内交易，继承了一些钱。他正坐在板凳上，在他协助经营的一家莫特街画廊外喝拿铁。他戴着一顶软塌塌的蓝色帽子和墨镜，在那里晒了45分钟太阳，看起来生活很惬意，简直到了极乐的程度。
Loafing. I would say that a lot of my life is loafing, and with spurts of activity in between, sort of trying to make up for loafing. I am loafing. Loafing is me.
游手好闲。我会说我的生活大部分时间都是在游手好闲，中间穿插着一阵阵的忙碌，算是为了弥补之前的游手好闲。我就是游手好闲。游手好闲就是我。
What do you think of the 9-to-5ers, people you see going into the subway at 8:30 and all that stuff?
你怎么看那些“9到5”上班族，就是那些你看到在8点半进地铁的人之类的？
When I was a kid, I had summer jobs where I worked 9:00 to 5:00. And I wore a suit and a tie. My uncle ran Simon & Schuster, the publishing house. And I went down there. And I took the subway to Rockefeller Center. And I did this and that. And I go, this is the way to go. And then something happened. Something happened along the way. And I think I went a little bit off that path, and I never got back on it. And once you get away from it, once you get away from being able to get up and go to work at 9:00 to 5:00, I think it would take a catastrophic lifestyle change or a major lifestyle change-- that's a bus pulling up in front of us-- to get me back into 9:00 to 5:00.
我小时候做过暑期工，早上9点工作到5点。我穿着西装，打着领带。我叔叔经营西蒙与舒斯特出版社。我去那里，搭地铁去洛克菲勒中心。我做这个做那个。我想，这就是该走的路。然后，发生了一些事。沿途发生了一些事。我觉得我稍微偏离了那条路，就再也没回去过。一旦你离开了它，一旦你离开了那种早上9点起床去上班到5点的生活，我想这需要一种灾难性的生活改变或者重大的生活改变——那是我们面前停下来的一辆公交车——才能让我回到9点到5点的工作中。
Do you feel sorry for those people at all?
你对那些人感到遗憾吗？
No, I admire them. I look at them, and in some ways, they make me feel inadequate, that they have somehow stuck nose to the grindstone. And I don't decry that as being something that I would never do. These people are heroes.
不，我钦佩他们。我看着他们，在某种程度上，他们让我觉得自己不够格，他们不知怎么地就能坚持脚踏实地工作。我并不排斥那种我永远不会做的事。这些人是英雄。
While people like Howard are basking peacefully in the sun, the heroes are inside at their desks. They're looking at the clock, tired of the stress, the forced social interaction, the meetings, the constant threat of having to think, and say things to and smile at the same old coworkers, some of whom have become intolerable, talking on the phone loudly, laughing without justification, making slurping noises during their lunch.
当像霍华德这样的人在阳光下平静地享受时光时，那些英雄们却坐在办公桌前。他们盯着时钟，厌倦了压力、被迫的社交互动、会议，厌倦了不得不时刻思考，以及对着那些老同事微笑并说话，其中有些人已经变得令人难以忍受，他们大声打电话，无缘无故地大笑，午餐时发出吧唧嘴的声音。
So the heroes do what any reasonable person would do. They stop working while they're at work, click around, check their stocks, shuffle to the office kitchen. Howard, at least, admits he's taking it easy. And he's outside, where the daytime hours have their own poetry, like the hours of 2:00 to 4:00.
所以英雄们做任何理智的人都会做的事。他们在工作时间停止工作，点点鼠标，查看股票，磨磨蹭蹭地走到办公室厨房。霍华德至少承认他在偷懒。而且他在外面，白天的时光有它自己的诗意，就像下午2点到4点一样。
Between 2:00 and 4:00 is a very interesting time because the feeling of it, the day changes almost the most from 2:00 to 4:00. And--
下午2点到4点是一个非常有趣的时刻，因为那种感觉，白天的变化在2点到4点之间最为明显。而且——
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
（交叉声音）
--the feeling?
——那种感觉？
Well, the shadows get longer. People start to get a little more energized. I think this is a-- the evening crowd, the night people, start to sort of stir at around 2:00 to 4:00. And there's a little more energy.
嗯，影子变长了。人们开始变得更有活力。我认为这是——傍晚的人群，夜间活动的人，开始在2点到4点左右活跃起来。而且有更多的能量。
But playing hooky from the 9 to 5 world isn't all lyrical musings about the changing of the light. None of us is going to feel sorry for any of these people. But there is a special kind of anxiety that's particular to skipping the normal work week. It can take a little while to get used to the idea that the regular world just goes on about its business without you. This is my friend Doug Elliott, who made some money as a lawyer and now doesn't work a 9 to 5 job.
但是从朝九晚五的世界里翘班并不全是关于光线变化的抒情冥想。我们谁也不会为这些人感到难过。但有一种特殊的焦虑，是逃避正常工作周所特有的。可能需要一段时间才能适应普通世界在你缺席的情况下照常运转这一事实。这是我的朋友道格·埃利奥特，他当律师挣了些钱，现在不再做9到5的工作了。
Walking around outside-- because New York is such a business-oriented city-- when people are walking around on the streets during the day, there's this sense of energy and going from this place to that place. And they're heading there, and they have direction. And I'm outside. I don't have any place I have to be. And I'm not part of that group.
在外面走动——因为纽约是一个以商业为导向的城市——当人们白天在街上走动时，有一种能量感，从这个地方到那个地方。他们正前往那里，他们有方向。而我在外面，我没有任何必须去的地方。我不属于那个群体。
Doug spends his days on no particular schedule, negotiating business deals, writing short stories that so far haven't been published, and puttering around.
道格的日子没什么特别的日程，他处理商业交易，写些至今未发表的短篇小说，四处转转。
Because I don't have a typical 9 to 5 job, the reality is that I'm never free. I'm never not working. I don't have that sense of closure to the day, ever, ever, ever. I always feel like there's something more I could be doing, there's something more I-- I walk into the bathroom, and I'll take work in with me.
因为我没有典型的9到5工作，现实是我从不自由。我从不停止工作。我永远、永远、永远没有那种一天结束的终结感。我总是觉得还有更多事要做，还有更多我——我走进洗手间，都会把工作带进去。
Doug and I headed outside, wandered through Union Square Park, the Heartland Brewery, Barnes and Noble, and ended up at the Old Town Bar. A few solitary drinkers were there. Doug ordered vodka. I got whiskey.
道格和我走到外面，漫步在联合广场公园、心泉啤酒厂、巴诺书店，最后在老城酒吧停下。几个孤独的酒客在那里。道格点了伏特加。我点了威士忌。
Now it was almost 5:00 on Friday, the end of the traditional work week. That stillness and dreamy quality of daytime was being replaced by Manhattan noise and energy as little groups of 9 to 5ers filed into the Old Town. We watch them. They've clearly come straight from the office, excited that at last the drinking begins. At last, they've earned the right to recreation so circumscribed that its duration is even included in its name-- Happy Hour.
现在快到周五下午5点了，传统工作周的结束。白天的那种宁静和梦幻感正被曼哈顿的噪音和活力所取代，一小群一小群的朝九晚五族涌入老城酒吧。我们看着他们。他们显然刚从办公室出来，兴奋地发现终于可以开始喝酒了。终于，他们赢得了娱乐的权利，这种权利被限制得连时长都被包含在名字里——欢乐时光。
George Gurley is a reporter for the New York Observer , for whom he first investigated the secret life of daytime loafers.
乔治·格利是《纽约观察家报》的记者，他最初就是为该报调查了白天游手好闲者的秘密生活。
[MUSIC - "NICE WORK IF YOU CAN GET IT" BY BILLIE HOLIDAY]
（音乐 - 比莉·哈乐黛《Nice Work If You Can Get It》）
Act Two, In a World Full of Soybeans, the Men Turn to Love. Let us now head to a grain elevator on the outskirts of Lincoln, Nebraska, rising 150 feet above cornfields and railroad tracks, holding over a million bushels of corn, soybeans, wheat, and milo. Meghan Daum explains how the daylight hours are spent there.
第二幕，《在充满大豆的世界里，男人们转向了爱情》。让我们前往林肯市郊区的一座谷物仓库，它高耸在玉米地和铁轨上方150英尺处，装载着超过一百万蒲式耳的玉米、大豆、小麦和糜子。梅根·道姆解释了在那里如何度过白天时光。
Grain elevators are, in many ways, the skyscrapers of rural America. They're the structures in the far corner of the paintings, the towers that pierce an otherwise uninterrupted sky. There are five men who work in one particular grain elevator in Lincoln. And they spend their days at one end or the other of two extremes. During harvest time, they've been known to work more than 48 hours straight. But in the winter and early spring, when crops lie dormant under layers of frost, and just a few farm trucks pull in over the course of the day, the workers at this grain elevator have something else on their minds.
谷物仓库在很多方面是美国农村的摩天大楼。它们是画作远角的结构，是刺破不间断天空的塔楼。有五个男人在林肯的一家特定谷物仓库工作。他们白天的时间都在两个极端的某一段度过。在收获季节，他们曾连续工作超过48小时。但在冬天和初春，当庄稼在霜层下休眠，一天只有几辆农用卡车开进来时，这家谷物仓库的工人们心里有别的事情。
We have so much to teach each other. And I have so much to give to you and so much to share with you.
我们有太多东西要教给彼此了。我有太多东西要给你，太多东西要和你分享。
Yeah, we are working yet. But every now and then, if a truck comes in during a commercial, it's kind of nice. It's when they come in right in the middle of the heated up things is when it gets kind of bad.
是啊，我们还在工作。但如果偶尔在广告时间有卡车进来，那倒也不错。在火热的剧情中间进来才最糟糕。
I can't wait to give birth to you. And I can't wait to just kiss your face, hold you in my arms.
我等不及要为你分娩了。我等不及要亲吻你的脸，把你抱在怀里。
How much you want to bet she has a miscarriage?
你猜她会流产的几率是多少？
That could well be.
很有可能。
Every day at 11:00 AM, these men stop what they're doing, get out their sandwiches or heat up some Chinese food, and gather together in front of the small television set in the office to watch the soap opera The Young and the Restless. They've been watching it for years. This is no casual viewing. It's an obsession.
每天上午11点，这些男人就会停下手中的活，拿出三明治或加热一些中餐，聚在办公室的小电视机前观看肥皂剧《不安分的青春》。他们已经看了好多年了。这不是随意的观看。这是一种痴迷。
I have a question for you, a very important question to me. Son, I need to understand why a boy your age, with everything going for you, feels the need to obliterate himself with alcohol.
我有一个问题要问你，一个对我来说非常重要的问题。儿子，我需要明白为什么像你这个年纪的男孩，拥有一切前途，却觉得有必要用酒精摧毁自己。
Because you did.
因为你做过。
Mom's a notorious alcoholic.
妈妈是个臭名昭著的酒鬼。
Oh, really?
哦，真的吗？
Yeah. She lost another son to alcohol some years ago.
是啊。几年前她又因为酒精失去了一个儿子。
The five men who work in this elevator seem, for the most part, just like the kind of guys you'd expect to load grain off of trucks and onto trains by the ton. Most are thick and burly. They have calloused hands, wear heavy work boots, and are often completely covered in dust. But their knowledge of The Young and the Restless is encyclopedic. They talk about it the way guys talk about sports. They do a lot of yelling at the screen. They argue about who's stalking the young, saucy Victoria Newman. They have lengthy discussions about a business tycoon's missing sperm sample and where it will end up. Noel, the supervisor, patiently explains to me how it is that Mackenzie, an orphan, ended up in Genoa City, the fictional setting of the show.
在这家仓库工作的五个男人，大部分看起来就像你会预想到的那种把成吨的谷物从卡车装到火车上的人。大多数人又粗又壮。他们双手粗糙，穿着厚重的工作靴，经常浑身沾满灰尘。但他们对《不安分的青春》的了解简直是百科全书式的。他们谈论它的方式就像男人谈论体育一样。他们对着屏幕大喊大叫。他们争论是谁在跟踪年轻、俏皮的维多利亚·纽曼。他们进行长篇大论，讨论商业大亨丢失的精子样本最终会落到哪里。主管诺埃尔耐心地向我解释了孤儿麦肯齐是如何来到该剧虚构的背景地热那亚城的。
Her father was a missionary in India and was presumed dead in a raid on a village. And he didn't even know he had this daughter, I don't think. He'd had it by a woman in town. And I don't know who she was, where she's gone.
她的父亲曾是印度的传教士，在一次村庄突袭中被推定死亡。而且我觉得他甚至不知道自己有这个女儿。那是他和镇上的一个女人生的。我不知道那是谁，她去了哪里。
She's in St. Louis right now because Jill went to St. Louis looking for the mother to find out if Mac is Brock's daughter.
她现在在圣路易斯，因为吉尔去圣路易斯寻找母亲，想查明麦克是不是布洛克的女儿。
That's Rick. He's 39 and has been doing grain elevator work for 10 years. He's married, has a six-year-old son and a job on the side as an exterminator.
那是瑞克。他39岁，做谷物仓库工作10年了。他结婚了，有一个六岁的儿子，还在做一份灭虫员的副业。
If I'm at home by myself and my wife and my kids are gone, I'll sit there, and I'll pop a beer about 11 o'clock and sit there and watch soaps.
如果我一个人在家，老婆孩子都不在，我会坐在那里，大约11点开一瓶啤酒，坐着看肥皂剧。
When he was a kid in the early '70s, he watched The Young and the Restless with his mom and his sisters. And these days, he's responsible for telling his wife what's going on in the show. He's even been known to read Soap Opera Digest while standing in line at the supermarket.
70年代初他还是个孩子时，就和妈妈及姐妹们一起看《不安分的青春》。如今，他负责告诉妻子剧情的发展。他甚至会在超市排队时阅读《肥皂剧文摘》。
So what do a bunch of relatively macho guys see in a show that's supposedly targeted at women? I can tell you that when the men at the grain elevator watch, they keep a running commentary during the love scenes, but sit in rapt attention when the characters talk business. And maybe the show was designed with this in mind. For every mushy relationship story, there are bank buyouts and shady business deals involving Jack Abbott's company, Jabot, and Jack's nemesis, Victor Newman.
那么，一群相对大男子主义的男人在一部据说是针对女性的电视剧里看到了什么？我可以告诉你，当谷物仓库的男人们观看时，他们在爱情戏中会进行现场评论，但在角色谈论生意时则全神贯注。也许这部剧在设计时就考虑到了这一点。每有一个多愁善感的恋爱故事，就会有银行收购和涉及杰克·阿博特的公司Jabot以及杰克宿敌维克多·纽曼的阴暗商业交易。
That's really the best part of the show, Victor trying to get back Jabot and buying all the banks and all that. We watch another one. It's Bold and Beautiful . And everybody's crying on that show at least once a day. It's more mushy. It was pretty good for about a year. And then all of a sudden, it just died off. But we still watch it, though.
那真的是剧中最棒的部分，维克多试图夺回Jabot，收购所有银行之类的。我们看另一部，《大胆而美丽》。剧里每个人一天至少哭一次。那更感性。它演得不错大约一年。然后突然间，它就没落了。但我们还是会看。
For these guys, the fascination with The Young and the Restless has a lot to do with one character, the enigmatic, inscrutable Victor Newman. When Victor's on screen, the men are silent. With his ambiguous, foreign sounding accent, the dignified gray around his temples, and the trademark leather sport coat that suggests he's far too important to wear an ordinary business suit, Victor is power incarnate. You can't describe him without sounding like a soap opera. Women want him. Men idolize him.
对于这些人来说，对《不安分的青春》的着迷与一个角色有很大关系：神秘、高深莫测的维克多·纽曼。当维克多出现在屏幕上时，男人们都沉默了。凭借他那模棱两可、听起来像是外籍的口音，鬓角庄严的灰白，以及那件暗示他身份高贵到无需穿普通商务西装的招牌皮质运动外套，维克多就是权力的化身。如果不听起来像是在谈论肥皂剧，你没法描述他。女人想要他，男人崇拜他。
The way he talks, and he's got that whisper, and when he raises his voice-- When he raises his voice, that means he's pretty upset about something. And whatever Victor wants, Victor gets, because he's got all the money that you can think of. He's buying all the banks so he can get back at Jack.
他说话的方式，他那种低语，还有当他提高嗓门时——当他提高嗓门，意味着他为此事非常心烦。无论维克多想要什么，他都能得到，因为他有你所能想到的一切金钱。他在收购所有银行，为了报复杰克。
And he told Jack, when he wanted to get company back-- he walked into his office where Jack was sitting in the chair acting like a big hot-shot. He put his hands in his pockets, and he leaned back. And he whispered, and he whispered. And then he gradually walked over to the fireplace. He grabbed this picture off the fireplace, turned around, and slapped it on top of some kind of trophy, and screamed and says, "I'm going to crush you. Just remember that." And then he put his hands on this collar, tucked in, shrugged his shoulders, and he walked out like a gentleman. An then Jack, I'm telling you, he was scared to death.
他告诉杰克，当他想夺回公司时——他走进杰克的办公室，杰克正坐在椅子上摆出一副大人物的样子。他把手插在兜里，向后靠着。他低语，不停地低语。然后他慢慢走向壁炉。他从壁炉上抓起一张照片，转过身，拍在某种奖杯上，尖叫着说：“我要摧毁你。记住这一点。”然后他整理了一下领口，耸了耸肩，像个绅士一样走了出去。而杰克，我告诉你，他吓坏了。
Victor is a force that seems to spin like a tornado across the fields that surround the elevator. Around here, soaps are watched as closely as the weather.
维克多是一股似乎像龙卷风一样横扫仓库周围田野的力量。在这里，看肥皂剧和看天气预报一样密切。
We work in a farming area. And a lot of the farmers I talk to, they'll come in with their grain. Or if they're out in the field, they always take their lunch. And I would say, probably 90% of the farmers and their wives come in, have their lunch, and watch the soaps. We'll sit here and talk on the phone even about that. But they're taking that lunch break, and they're watching the show.
我们在农业区工作。我交谈过的很多农民，他们会带着谷物过来。或者如果他们在田里，他们总是带着午餐。我会说，大概90%的农民和他们的妻子会进来，吃午餐，看肥皂剧。我们甚至会在电话里谈论这个。但他们休息时，都在看那部戏。
During the slow months, the TV will stay on after The Young and the Restless. And if the men aren't doing anything else, they'll come into the office and watch other soaps. But in a month or so, late spring will warm up the fields. And things will get busier and busier until harvest time, when the work will be nonstop. As Noel dumps 250 bushels of soybeans into the truck pit, a load from one of just a few trucks that came in today, you can only imagine what it's like to get 100 or more of these trucks every day, and then spend the night loading them into trains a mile long.
在淡季，电视在《不安分的青春》结束后还会一直开着。如果男人们没什么事，他们会进办公室看其他肥皂剧。但过了一个月左右，晚春会让田野暖和起来。事情会越来越忙，直到收获季节，那时工作将不停歇。当诺埃尔将250蒲式耳大豆倾倒入卡车坑时——这是今天进来的少数卡车之一——你只能想象如果每天有100多辆这样的卡车，然后晚上花一整晚把它们装进长达一英里的火车里是什么感觉。
These are great beans. This year, almost all the crops in Nebraska were real good quality.
这些是很好的豆子。今年，内布拉斯加州几乎所有的作物质量都非常好。
These guys might miss some episodes come fall. By then, the stalker might have been caught. The father of Ashley's baby might be revealed. And Victor's sperm sample might have been put to use.
到了秋天，这些人可能会错过一些剧集。到那时，跟踪狂可能已经被抓住了。阿什莉孩子的父亲可能已经揭晓。维克多的精子样本可能已经派上用场了。
But part of the beauty of soaps is that they move so slowly, that you can miss months, even years, and still be able to catch up in a few days. Soaps are nothing if not daily reminders of the virtues of patience. Just as the farming community waits for the seasons to change, waits for the corn to grow, waits for the price of grain to rise enough so that they might turn a profit, they wait for something to actually happen on The Young and the Restless . We hear enough these days about how fast the world is moving. Maybe it's good to know that there's still a place in America where stalkers are at large and sperm samples are up for grabs, but where time moves slowly.
但肥皂剧的部分美妙之处在于它们进展如此缓慢，以至于你可以错过几个月甚至几年，依然能在几天内赶上进度。肥皂剧是对耐心这一美德的每日提醒。正如农业社区等待季节更替、等待玉米生长、等待谷物价格上涨到足以获利一样，他们也在等待《不安分的青春》里真的发生点什么。我们现在听够了世界运转得有多快。或许知道在美国仍有一个地方，跟踪狂还在逍遥法外，精子样本还在被人争抢，但时间却缓慢流逝，这感觉不错。
Meghan Daum in Lincoln. Coming up, neither rain nor sleet nor snow-- if you know what I mean. Delivering the mail on the West side of Chicago, where the only people in the streets during the day are drug dealers-- do people even use the word snow for drugs anymore? We don't even bother to answer that question. In a minute, from Public Radio International, when our program continues.
这是在林肯的梅根·道姆。稍后，无论风雨雷雪——如果你们明白我的意思的话。在芝加哥西区送信，那里的白天街道上只有毒贩——人们还用“雪”这个词来代指毒品吗？我们甚至懒得回答那个问题。稍后回来，来自国际公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week in our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Our program today, The Secret Life of Daytime, stories of all the things that are happening in the world unnoticed in broad daylight, things that many of us miss because we are stuck at our jobs.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来围绕该主题的各种不同故事。我们今天的节目是《白天的秘密生活》，讲述在光天化日之下世界上正在发生的、未被察觉的各种事情，这些事情许多人因为忙于工作而错过了。
We've arrived at Act Three of our show. Act Three, The Geography of Childhood. In the early 1970s, a geographer named Roger Hart did a study of exactly where it is that children go during the daytime. For two years, he followed 86 children, all the children in a small town in Vermont, during the hours when parents were away at work. In this rural setting, nearly every child, nearly every one, had a secret hiding place somewhere, a spot that adults usually did not know about. One little boy made a clearing in his parents' crop fields. Some sisters had a spot in an opening in the woods, a kind of playhouse with rocks from the river, that were set up as a pretend telephone and a pretend TV.
我们进入了节目的第三幕。第三幕，《童年的地理学》。在20世纪70年代初，一位名叫罗杰·哈特的地理学家对孩子们白天去的地方进行了研究。两年的时间里，他跟踪了佛蒙特州一个小镇上的86名孩子，就在父母上班的时间里。在这个农村环境中，几乎每个孩子，几乎每一个，都有一个秘密藏身处，一个大人们通常不知道的地方。一个小男孩在父母的农田里清理出一片空地。一些姐妹在树林里的空地上有一个点，是一个用河里的石头摆成的游戏屋，被当作假装的电话和电视。
The extraordinary quantity of these places in those days-- that is, in a town where children were free to do what they wanted-- sometimes, I would walk through a field of very tall grass, and then, find in the middle of the field a couple of shelves, beautifully decorated with lots of little objects on it, but no walls. And this was their special place.
在那个年代，这些地方的数量极其惊人——也就是说，在一个孩子们可以自由做他们想做之事的城镇里——有时，我会穿过一片很高的草地，然后在田野中间发现几个货架，装饰得非常漂亮，上面摆放着许多小物件，但没有墙壁。这就是他们的特殊空间。
Two children who I was just chatting with one day-- and I think they were four and five years old-- and they said, "Oh, yes, we'd love to show you our fern house." Well, I'd never seen a fern house before, so I followed them. And they had this little place that was a bower, really, of evergreen trees. And beneath it was fern that they would pick and then turn into beds and pillows. There were imaginary windows which they shared in their agreement the location of, but which could not be seen. And it was a very, very beautiful space.
有两个我某天聊过的孩子——我想他们分别是四岁和五岁——他们说：“噢，是的，我们很乐意向你展示我们的蕨类植物屋。”嗯，我以前从未见过蕨类植物屋，所以我跟着他们去了。他们有这个小地方，实际上是一个常绿树组成的凉亭。下面是他们采摘并变成床铺和枕头的蕨类植物。那里有共享的想象窗口，他们对此位置有默契，但却看不见。那是一个非常、非常美丽的场所。
It sounds so romantic.
听起来太浪漫了。
Yeah. The fact was, I happened to choose a small town then because I wanted something that was manageable for me to look at. Later on, I came and did research in New York City. And certainly, in this city, there's been lots of places that are also very special, built, created by children as part of their desire, commonly with one or two close friends, to create a special place that's removed from the adult world-- often on the rooftop, sometimes in the cellar, sometimes beneath a stoop.
是的。事实上，我当时恰好选择了一个小镇，因为我想找一个我能管理并观察的对象。后来，我来到纽约市进行了研究。当然，在这个城市里，也有许多地方非常特别，是孩子们为了满足自己的愿望而建立、创造的，通常是和一两个亲密朋友一起，为了创造一个远离成人世界的特殊场所——通常在屋顶，有时在地下室，有时在门廊下。
Why do you think it is that it was so common for children to have a secret place?
你认为为什么孩子们拥有秘密场所如此普遍？
They're engaging and developing a sense of self as something separate from others. That is a psychological struggle that takes a lifetime, from a very early age, when children, for example, turn a chair upside down and go inside it, and say, "This is my place." They're engaging in that kind of developing a sense of self.
他们正在参与并发展一种与他人分离的自我意识。那是一场持续一生的心理挣扎，从很小的时候开始，比如，当孩子们把椅子倒过来钻进去，说：“这是我的地方。”他们就在参与那种发展自我意识的过程。
Did you make actual maps?
你制作了实际的地图吗？
Oh, yes. I've got one map of just three houses, which show all the places they transformed in one year. And there was, I think, seven children there. And there's probably 14 locations that are either little houses or racing tracks, or villages or cities, or airports that they built.
噢，是的。我有一张仅仅三个房子的地图，展示了他们一年内改造的所有地方。我想那里有七个孩子。大概有14个位置，或者是他们建造的小房子、赛车道、村庄、城市或机场。
In a small town like you were studying, was daytime, in particular, the province of children? The town kind of belonged to the kids?
在你研究的那种小镇里，白天尤其属于孩子吗？这个镇子某种程度上属于孩子们？
Yes, I think that used to be true even in cities. The greatest users of the outdoor space were children and, ironically, the elderly. They're the people who have to find close to home an interesting environment for themselves.
是的，我认为那甚至在城市里也曾经是真的。户外空间最大的使用者是孩子，讽刺的是，还有老人。他们是那些不得不在家附近为自己找到一个有趣环境的人。
So the world has changed enormously for children. Children now spend much more of their time in either programmed activities or supervised activities, under surveillance, you might say. Children are not outside. You don't see kids in the street in most neighborhoods. You don't hear them at night or in the early evening like you used to.
所以世界对于孩子来说已经发生了巨大的变化。孩子们现在花费更多时间在程序化的活动或监督下的活动中，可以说是在监控下。孩子们不在外面。你在大多数社区看不到街上的孩子。你听不到他们像以前那样在晚上或傍晚玩耍。
Well, I know with kids who live here in the city of Chicago, parents are careful about their kids, simply won't let them out. And the worse the neighborhood, the more strictly the kids are controlled. And so their daytime space, literally, is just in the living room in front of the television.
嗯，我知道对于住在这里芝加哥市的孩子们来说，父母对孩子很小心，根本不让他们出门。社区越差，对孩子的控制就越严格。所以他们的白天空间，实际上，只是电视机前的客厅里。
Yeah. Even in the daytime, also, rural America children don't have the freedom they used to. There's fears everywhere.
是的。即使在白天，农村地区的美国孩子也没有了他们曾经拥有的自由。到处都有恐惧。
Geographer Roger Hart. He published his findings in a book called Children's Experience of Place, now out of print. You can see a few of his maps on the geography of childhood on the This American Life website, www.thislife.org.
地理学家罗杰·哈特。他将研究结果出版在一本名为《儿童的地方体验》的书中，现已绝版。你可以在《美国生活》的网站www.thislife.org上看到一些关于童年地理的地图。
Act Four, Invisible Man. It's not just children and the elderly who are left in quiet, residential neighborhoods when the working people have vacated to go to work. Other people pass through. They see things. This American Life producer Alex Bumberg spent a few hours with a Chicago postman to find out what exactly it is that he sees.
第四幕，《隐形人》。当上班族们离家去上班时，留在安静住宅区的不仅仅是孩子和老人。还有其他人经过。他们看到了事情。《美国生活》制片人亚历克斯·邦伯格花了几小时与一位芝加哥邮递员在一起，以找出他到底看到了什么。
When a botanist walks through a neighborhood, he might classify the houses he sees by what kind of trees are growing in the yard. That one has an old maple growing next to it, this one an oak. It only makes sense, then, that when a mailman walks through a neighborhood, he has his own system.
当植物学家穿过一个街区时，他可能会根据院子里生长的树种来分类他看到的房子。那间屋子旁边长着一棵老枫树，这间屋子是橡树。那么，当邮递员穿过一个社区时，他有自己的一套系统也就不足为奇了。
On this route here, you'll find that there are many different mailboxes. Just about every mail receptacle there is, you'll find on this route here. You have your mailboxes, you have your mail slots, you have a wall of mailboxes. There are many different sizes. You'll see the different forms as we make these deliveries.
在这条路线上，你会发现有很多不同的邮箱。几乎这里存在的每种邮件接收设施，你都能在这条路线上找到。你有你的邮箱，你有投递口，你有一排邮箱。有很多不同的大小。当我们进行这些投递时，你会看到不同的形式。
I'm Henry. I'm the mailman on the far west side here. And we're on a street now, one of the blocks that I deliver. And so far, it looks like a vacant street. The only thing that's moving now is a car. Maybe I see two men, one of them working on a lawn. And down the block, which I can see a guy standing about two blocks down. Now, what he's doing or what he's waiting on, I have no idea.
我是亨利。我是这儿远西区的邮递员。我们现在在一条街上，我投递的街区之一。到目前为止，看起来像是一条空荡荡的街道。现在唯一在移动的东西是一辆车。也许我看到了两个人，其中一个在打理草坪。在街区尽头，我能看到一个人站在两个街区外。至于他在做什么或在等什么，我一无所知。
Actually, Henry's lying. He has some idea. After all, there's only two categories of people he sees on this part of his route during the day-- elderly retirees and gang members. The guy on the corner, he's not elderly. But Henry's worked this neighborhood for 20 years. And he has to come back here every day. So no matter how many times I ask him to be more explicit, he never refers to these guys we're passing as drug dealers or gang members. He calls them businessmen, workers, or boys in the 'hood.
事实上，亨利在撒谎。他知道一些。毕竟，他在白天在这段路线上见到的人只有两类——老年退休人员和帮派成员。角落里的那个人不是老人。但亨利在这个社区工作了20年。他必须每天回到这里。所以无论我多少次要求他说明得更具体，他从不把我们经过的这些人称为毒贩或帮派成员。他称他们为商人、工人或街区男孩。
Hello, dear.
你好，亲爱的。
You've got company.
你有客人了。
Yeah, you got something for me?
是啊，有什么给我吗？
The retirees, he calls "dear." And a surprising number are waiting for him at the door.
那些退休人员，他称之为“亲爱的”。而且有惊人数量的人在门口等他。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
（交叉声音）
Yeah. How's Carlton?
是的。卡尔顿怎么样？
He's doing pretty good.
他挺好的。
That's good.
那很好。
Yeah.
是啊。
Yeah, I've been knowing her since I came out here many years ago, many years ago.
是的，我很多年前来这里的时候就认识她了，很多年前了。
You take care of my friend, now.
你替我照顾好我的朋友。
I will.
我会的。
OK. All right. Have a good day.
好的。好的。祝你愉快。
All right, now.
好的。
We're the eyes and ears sometimes on elderly people. We see the mail piling up in the box or whatever, something is wrong. You put the mail in there, it's in there for two or three days, something's wrong. Let someone know something. There was one where I had to stop a police officer. There was a lady. She was an elderly lady, lord knows. She done passed now. But her door was open. And it's never open. It is never, ever open.
有时候我们是老年人的耳目。我们看到邮件在邮箱里堆积或者别的什么，就说明出问题了。你把邮件放进去，它在那里放了两三天，就是有问题。让某人知道出事了。有一次我不得不拦住一名警官。有一位女士。她是一位老太太，上帝知道。她现在已经过世了。但她的门开着。从来没开过。那是从来、从来没有开过的。
So I stopped a police officer and told him. I said that this lady here, she lives on my route and everything. But her door was wide open, and she never leaves it open. Fortunately for me, that particular time, the lady had fell again and hurt herself. So they were able to take her to the hospital. Just that once. But it's done happened in many cities and many different routes.
所以我拦住一名警官告诉了他。我说这位女士，她住我的线路，什么的。但她的门敞开着，而且她从不敞开它。幸运的是，那次，这位女士又摔倒受伤了。所以他们能够送她去医院。就那一次。但这在许多城市和许多不同的线路上都发生过。
Henry and I turn down a side street. Several young men in starter jackets and baseball caps slouch against a parked car. Another guy stands on an opposite corner.
亨利和我转入一条侧街。几个穿着Starter夹克、戴着棒球帽的年轻男人靠在停着的车上。另一个人站在对面的街角。
Right now, as you see, there's only a few of them out. If you look on some of the corners, you'll find one or two of them out there. I told you it wouldn't be many. It is their 'hood. We just work in it.
现在，正如你所见，只有几个人在外面。如果你看一下某些街角，你会发现一两个人在那儿。我告诉过你不会有很多人。这是他们的街区。我们只是在这里工作。
And how do they perceive you?
他们怎么看待你？
Well, they perceive me as no threat. We're not friendly. There's a wave or hello or how you doing, and we go on about our business.
嗯，他们认为我没有威胁。我们不算友好。有个挥手、问候或是“你好吗”，然后我们继续忙自己的事。
As we walk by, I see one guy slap something into a second guy's outstretched palm. The second guy slips his hand into his pocket. The two never look at each other. What's weird is they make no effort to hide what clearly is a violation of federal drug policy in front of a federal employee. Henry says it's always like this.
当我们走过时，我看到一个人拍了什么东西到第二个人的伸出的手掌里。第二个人把手插进兜里。两人从不看对方。奇怪的是，他们竟然不在乎在一个联邦雇员面前公然违反联邦毒品政策。亨利说这总是这样。
Simply because they don't feel that I'm a threat to them. They do not feel that I'm a threat to them. If, by chance, you drove around in a big Ford, in most cases, they would slow down. Whatever activity was going on, they would stop because they'll get hesitant. But as far as I'm concerned, I'm not a threat. They know I'm not a threat. So they continue doing what they're gonna do. I have nothing more or less to do with-- They know that I'm not going to bother them, and they don't bother me.
仅仅是因为他们不觉得我是他们的威胁。他们不觉得我是他们的威胁。如果碰巧你开着一辆福特大车，在大多数情况下，他们会减速。无论正在进行什么活动，他们都会停下来，因为他们会迟疑。但就我而言，我不是威胁。他们知道我不是威胁。所以他们继续做他们打算做的事。我与他们的事没多大关系——他们知道我不会打扰他们，他们也不会打扰我。
So it's just like you're sort of-- it'd be like stopping just because a cloud crosses the sky or something.
所以这就好像你有点——这就像仅仅因为云朵飘过天空或什么的而停下来。
Exactly, exactly, exactly. Exactly right.
正是，正是，正是。完全正确。
You're just sort of a part of the day.
你只是白天的一部分。
I'm a part of the day. Matter of fact, it seems like I'm part of the fixture. There are things that happen naturally. It rains naturally. You have no say in that. When the sun comes out, you have no say in that. if someone-- Hey, how're you doing there?-- If someone dies, you have no control over that. Same with the mailman. You have no control over the mailman coming into your block or not. Mailman's going to be on every block, and that's regardless.
我是白天的一部分。事实上，看起来我就是固定设施的一部分。有些事情是自然发生的。下雨是自然的。你对此没有发言权。当太阳出来时，你对此没有发言权。如果有人——嘿，你好吗？——如果有人死了，你对那个没有控制力。邮递员也一样。你对邮递员是否进入你的街区没有控制力。邮递员会出现在每个街区，这是肯定的。
There was a situation where the guy moved. And he filed a change of address card, which is his responsibility, because otherwise, we wouldn't know where he's at.
有一次那个人搬家了。他提交了一张地址变更卡，这是他的责任，否则我们不知道他在哪里。
Right. And this is a customer that you've known. He's been on your route.
对。这是一个你认识的客户。他在你的路线上。
I've known him for a while. He had been on the route for about two or three years. Well what it was, I was coming up to his house. He decides that he's going to take him a check or have me write him one. This is the impression that I'm getting because I've already told him it's been forwarded to his new address.
我认识他很久了。他在这个路线上大约两三年了。嗯，是这样的，我走到他家。他决定要拿一张支票或者让我写一张。这是我得到的印象，因为我已经告诉他支票已经被转发到他的新地址了。
And what's he saying to you specifically?
他具体跟你说了什么？
Well, he's telling me, "You're going to give me my check. You're going to give me my check." And I keep telling him, "Well, it's been forwarded to your new address." Told him it'd probably be there tomorrow or the day after. And he says, well, he can't wait. And it looked like he was going to whoop me or something because he was taking his jacket off. And when he came to me, the boys in the 'hood surrounded him, told him, "That's my mailman. You don't mess with him." So he went on about his business. No problem.
嗯，他告诉我，“你要把我的支票给我。你要把我的支票给我。”我一直告诉他，“嗯，它已经被转发到你的新地址了。”告诉他可能明天或后天就会到那里。他说，嗯，他等不及了。看起来他好像要打我什么的，因为他在脱夹克。当我走到他面前时，街区里的男孩们围住了他，告诉他，“那是我的邮递员。你别惹他。”所以他就去忙他的事了。没问题。
So what did you say to those guys when that happened?
那件事发生时你对那些人说了什么？
Oh, I just thanked them-- How're you doing, dear?-- I just thanked them for what they did. They told me, "No problem." They say, "Because you've been around here too long for anybody to be messing with you."
噢，我只是感谢他们——你好吗，亲爱的？——我只是感谢他们所做的一切。他们告诉我，“没问题。”他们说，“因为你在这里呆得太久了，没人会惹你。”
Good morning. How're you doing?
早上好。你好吗？
After two hours of walking, we've come across only a handful of people, maybe a half a dozen workers, one guy home from his job on vacation, standing and surveying his front lawn, four or five disembodied voices exchanging pleasantries through the mail slot. In short, the people left in a primarily residential neighborhood during non-residential hours. Henry doesn't get lonely, though. The fewer people, the better. In fact, he says he likes winter best, the empty days in mid-January, when it's only him and the occasional drug dealer on the street. But if there's no one on the street, especially if the weather's OK, that's when he gets worried.
走了一个小时后，我们只碰到了少数几个人，也许半打工人，一个人度假在家，站在那里观察他的草坪，四五声模糊的对话通过邮件槽交换寒暄。简而言之，在非住宅时间留在一个主要是住宅区的人。亨利并不觉得孤独。人越少越好。事实上，他说他最喜欢冬天，一月中旬那些空旷的日子，那时街上只有他和偶尔出现的毒贩。但如果街上一个人都没有，特别是如果天气还不错，那才是他担心的时候。
Anytime the workers disappear for a period of time, that's when you start more or less thinking more safety. You figure it should be some people out here today, but it's not. That's the scary part. Because in most cases, if there's been noise outside all along, every day, then all of a sudden, there's nothing, something has happened somewhere or something will happen. Always look at it that way.
无论什么时候，工人如果消失了一段时间，那才是你开始更多地考虑安全问题的时候。你觉得今天应该有些人出来，但却没有。那才是可怕的部分。因为在大多数情况下，如果外面一直都有动静，每天都有，然后突然之间，什么都没有了，说明某处发生了什么事或者将会发生什么事。总是这么看。
And you feel that way. You feel like you can--
你感觉到了。你感觉好像你能——
You can feel it. You can feel it. It makes you start looking. It makes you start checking. You can feel the thing like your hair's just raised up on the back of your neck, that type of thing. That's the same feeling you get out here sometimes when it's supposed to be crowded out here, supposed to be people out here, but there's absolutely nobody but you. And you want to get away as soon as possible. Let me hurry up and do what I have to do so I can get out.
你能感觉到。你能感觉到。这让你开始观察。这让你开始检查。你能感觉到那种毛孔耸立、后颈发凉的感觉。当你觉得外面应该是拥挤的，应该是有人在外的，但却绝对没有人只有你时，你有时也会有这种感觉。你想尽快离开。让我赶紧做完我必须做的事，好离开这里。
On days like that, other people could avoid this block, take another route. Henry doesn't have that choice. He has to stick to his.
在那些日子，其他人可能会避开这条街，走另一条路。亨利没得选。他必须坚守自己的线路。
I'm surprised to see you. Why aren't you at work?
看到你我很惊讶。为什么没去上班？
I'm on vacation for a week.
我放了一周假。
Oh, are you? See, that's why I need a job where I go on vacation.
哦，是吗？你看，这就是为什么我需要一份能让我去度假的工作。
Alex Blumberg.
亚历克斯·布卢姆伯格。
Yeah, sooner or later, if y'all don't hurt me out here first.
是啊，迟早，如果你们没先在外面伤害我的话。
[MUSIC - "WHOOPIE TI-YI-YO" BY SONS OF THE PIONEERS]
（音乐 - 荒野之子《Whoopie Ti-Yi-Yo》）
Act Five, $82.50 a Day. Some neighborhoods are wealthy enough that they somehow keep those unsightly drug dealers off the corners. There, the daytime hours are filled with other kinds of people. In some places, it's children's nannies who occupy the lovely houses during the day with their own second community, second set of lives, in the same space. Mona Simpson has this excerpt from a forthcoming novel. The excerpt is told in the voice of a Filipino nanny named Wanda, somebody who's part of a community of Filipino nannies in Santa Monica, California.
第五幕，《每天82.5美元》。有些社区足够富有，以至于它们不知怎么地把那些碍眼的毒贩赶出了角落。在那里，白天的时光被其他种类的人填满。在某些地方，是儿童保姆在白天占领了那些可爱的房子，在同一空间内拥有她们自己的第二个社区、第二套生活。莫娜·辛普森摘录了即将出版的小说。这段文字以一位名叫万达的菲律宾保姆的口吻讲述，她是加利福尼亚州圣莫尼卡市菲律宾保姆社区的一员。
Ruth told me when I first came here, "I don't need to teach you children. You have been a mother to five," she said. "You know. Children are not hard. But most, you have to think about the mother. Here, the mothers are the ones who throw the tantrums. You may have had nannies, but you have not before been a nanny."
我刚到这里时露丝告诉我，“我不需要教你照顾孩子。你已经做过五个孩子的母亲了，”她说。“你懂的。孩子不难。但大多数时候，你必须考虑母亲。在这里，母亲才是那个会闹脾气的人。你可能雇过保姆，但你以前没当过保姆。”
I hold my hands open in front of me to take away whatever my employer is beginning. If she starts to sew a button, I finish. If she is rinsing a lettuce, I say, "I will be the one." When the guy spills something and pounds a wet napkin at the spot, I reach out my hands and say, "Give it to me. I will make it clean," all the while, with a smile. It is not hard. No, not when you have a purpose. And I have five purposes, the youngest 17, entering medicine.
我张开双手，去处理雇主开始的任何琐事。如果她开始缝一颗扣子，我就完成它。如果她在冲洗生菜，我说，“让我来吧。”当那个家伙泼洒了东西，用湿纸巾拍打污点时，我伸出双手说，“给我吧。我会清理干净的，”全程都面带微笑。这并不难。不，当你有一个目标时。而我有五个目标，最小的17岁，正在学医。
But I have a good job. The parents of Richard get him in the morning. While they eat their breakfast, I fix their bed, take the glass of water from the side table, pick up Kleenexes. I straighten their bathroom, fasten the top to his toothpaste. Hers, it is already done. "Always the parents first," Ruth said. "A kid cannot fire you, even here. They can love you, but they cannot pay you. And anyway, they will forgive."
但我有一份好工作。理查德的父母在早上带他。当他们吃早餐时，我整理床铺，拿走床头桌上的水杯，捡起面巾纸。我整理他们的洗手间，给他的牙膏盖上盖子。她的，已经做好了。“永远把父母放在第一位，”露丝说。“孩子没法开除你，即使在这里。他们会爱你，但他们付不起钱。无论如何，他们会原谅。”
Ruth told me, "You have always to talk to him, even when he is still a baby. It is very important that they hear words." And I did, more than to my kids, because my kids I had one after the other, five in 10 years. But with Ricardo, I just talk and talk. I tell him everything, and now, see? He is very doll-doll. He understands more than 100 words Tagalog. In the class of 2010 at Harvard University, which is where the parents of Ricardo would like him to go, there will be 20 Santa Monica boys saying to the cooks in the cafeteria, "Excuse, where is my adobo?" And Wanda, by then, will be lying in a hammock, back in the Philippines. "What for?" Ricardo asks me. He is young. He does not yet understand rest.
露丝告诉我，“你必须始终和他说话，即使他还是个婴儿。重要的是他们听到话语。”我确实这么做了，比对我自己的孩子说得更多，因为我的孩子是一个接一个，十年里生了五个。但对里卡多，我只是不停地说。我告诉他一切，现在，看？他非常乖巧。他能听懂超过100个他加禄语单词。在哈佛大学2010届毕业班，也就是理查德父母希望他去的地方，会有20个圣莫尼卡男孩对食堂厨师说：“不好意思，我的阿多波在哪里？”而到那时，万达将躺在菲律宾老家的吊床上。“为了什么？”里卡多问我。他还小，还不懂得休息。
Ruth said, when I started with Ricardo, "I'm not going to tell you how to love him because either that will happen, or it won't." And in four jobs, 25 years, only once it did not happen to her. "And then, you need to quit. Because you cannot do the job if you do not love the baby. No," Ruth said to me at the beginning, "I will not tell you how to love. I wouldn't if I could. Because what I would tell you, if I knew, would be how not to so much. Because you will love him the same as your own, and they never do. They love you, but it is not the same." I told her then, "I know, I know. I am a mother, too." But now, I think, if you can keep them until they are five, then, they will never forget you.
当我开始照顾里卡多时，露丝说，“我不会告诉你如何去爱他，因为那要么会发生，要么不会。”在四份工作、25年里，只有一次没发生。“那样的话，你需要辞职。因为如果你不爱那个孩子，你就做不好这份工作。不，”露丝一开始对我说，“我不会告诉你如何去爱。就算我知道，我也不会。因为如果我知道，我会告诉你的，是怎么不爱得那么多。因为你会像爱自己的孩子一样爱他，但他们从不。他们爱你，但那是不一样的。”当时我告诉她，“我知道，我知道。我也是个母亲。”但现在，我想，如果你能把他们带到五岁，那么，他们永远不会忘记你。
I ask Ricardo, "Will you remember your Wanda?" "Why?" He says. "You are not going away." "Someday," I tell him, "I will return to the Philippines." "Why? What will you do there?" "I will go and sit at my house, stare at my diplomas."
我问里卡多，“你会记得你的万达吗？”“为什么？”他说。“你又不会走。”“有一天，”我告诉他，“我会回到菲律宾。”“为什么？你在那里做什么？”“我会回去坐在我的房子里，盯着我的毕业证书看。”
"Come on, come on, come on, come on, come on. Come to Wanda. I have something for you," I say, because he is very angry. Usually, it is the dad. But now, it was the mother he was hitting. She put a hand to her eye, and I got ice the way I do with his boo-boos. So I take him in my arms away.
“快点，快点，快点，快点，快点。过来万达这里。我有东西给你，”我说，因为他非常生气。通常是爸爸。但现在，是他正在打妈妈。她把手放在眼睛上，我像处理他磕碰伤那样拿来冰块。所以我把他从怀里抱开。
I am on the ground now, in the yard. And he is strong. I cannot so easily hold him still. And Wanda told a lie. I do not have anything for him. So I make promises. "Someday, I am going to take you home with me to the Philippines. And there, we will make the ice candy." He is still in my arms, but he is not any longer fighting. His bones, they are different now, not pushing to get out. They fall in the pattern, like the veins of a leaf.
我现在在院子里的地上。他很有力气。我没法那么容易地让他安静下来。万达撒了个谎。我没什么给他。所以我做出承诺。“有一天，我会带你跟我回菲律宾。在那里，我们要制作冰糖果。”他还在我怀里，但他不再挣扎了。他的骨头，现在感觉不一样了，不再想要冲出来。它们落入了一种模式，就像叶脉一样。
"I will put you in my pocket and feed you one candy every day. And you will be happy because the ocean at our place, it is very blue. The sky, it is higher than here. And the fruits that grow on trees, very sweet. His head is down to the ground between his own knees, but he is listening. He is better now, slower, his heart.
“我会把你装进我的口袋，每天喂你一颗糖果。你会很高兴的，因为我们那里的海，非常蓝。天空，比这里更高。长在树上的水果，非常甜。”他的头低垂在双膝之间，但他正在听。他现在好多了，心跳更慢了。
I see through the window his mother on the telephone. She holds the ice to her eye and walks around the kitchen, talking to her friend long distance, a woman who does not work and who reads many books about the raising of children. When my employer becomes upset, she calls this friend, the full-time mother.
我透过窗户看到他母亲在打电话。她把冰块敷在眼睛上，在厨房里走来走去，和她的朋友长途通话，那个不工作、读了很多关于养育孩子书籍的女人。当我的雇主心烦时，她就会给这个朋友打电话，那位全职母亲。
But he is better now. Only his mouth, it is still smeared outside the edges. He will come with me. I lift him into the stroller and promise him candy, not the ice candy, just candy we can buy here. "But do not tell your mother."
但他现在好多了。只有他的嘴，边缘还涂抹着。他会跟我走的。我把他抱进推车，承诺给他糖果，不是冰糖果，只是我们能在这里买到的普通糖果。“但别告诉你妈妈。”
I say, "Excuse, but we are going now." "Is that OK? Thank you, Wanda." This is how my employer believes she cannot live without me. She's telling her friend who reads the books how he is better with me than with her. And her friend will tell her that it is perfectly normal.
我说，“不好意思，我们要走了。”“那样可以吗？谢谢你，万达。”这就是为什么我的雇主相信她离不开我。她正告诉那个读过那些书的朋友，他和我在一起比和她在一起更好。而她的朋友会告诉她，那完全正常。
We are just alone, Ricardo and me. This neighborhood is ours during the daytime. You do not see the white mothers walking, only getting in and out of cars, carrying shopping bags. I am pushing him in the stroller, and he sits. That is the good of fighting. It makes them very tired.
我们只是单独待着，里卡多和我。这个社区白天属于我们。你见不到白人母亲在走路，她们只会进出汽车，提着购物袋。我推着他在推车里，他坐着。这就是打架的好处。这让他们非常累。
The sun is solid like many small weights on our arms. I pass by the park. And in the distance, we see friends, babysitters, and they wave. But he doesn't want to get out of his stroller. So we just roll under the tall trees.
阳光像许多小小的砝码一样扎实地压在我们的手臂上。我经过公园。在远处，我们看到了朋友、保姆，她们挥手。但他不想下推车。所以我们只是滚在大树下。
When we return home, I have ready a project. We are putting into cardboard all the coins in the house. Ricardo is doing it with me. And his mother told us we could use the pennies to put in the choo-choo bank, which is for our ticket to the Philippines.
当我们回到家，我已经准备好了一个项目。我们正把家里所有的硬币放进纸板里。里卡多正和我一起做。他母亲告诉我们，可以用这些便士放进“呜呜”存钱罐里，那是我们去菲律宾的机票钱。
I told my employers already, when they go to Europe to celebrate their 10th anniversary, I will take Ricardo to the Philippines. We are also finding nickels and dimes and quarters. And I have the brown tubes from the bank for those, too. "It is a hunt," I tell Ricardo. There is always money in this house, where people empty their pockets.
我已经告诉我的雇主了，当他们去欧洲庆祝结婚十周年时，我会带里卡多去菲律宾。我们还在寻找镍币、角币和硬币。我也有银行给的棕色管子装那些。“这是一种狩猎，”我告诉里卡多。这个屋子里总有钱，人们会掏空口袋。
Ricardo is a very good worker. We just pile the logs of finished coins. If we can also save the money that is for quarters and dimes and nickels, we will have a lot. Already I have saved $75. But I will have to find the right way to ask. The pennies, they are already ours. But the rest, I will ask the mother of Ricardo, not the dad.
里卡多是个很好的工人。我们只是把装满的硬币垒起来。如果我们也能存下角币和镍币的钱，我们就有很多了。我已经存了75美元。但我得找到合适的方式去问。便士已经属于我们了。但剩下的，我会问里卡多的母亲，而不是爸爸。
At the bank, we wait in line a long time. Then, when we get to the front, the lady is all business, making a total of the rolled dimes. I tell her, "This little man rolled the nickels by himself." When the lady finishes the silver, I begin to lift the bag of pennies from his wagon. They are heavy. We will get $40 from nickels, $27 from dimes, and $103 from pennies.
在银行，我们排了很长时间的队。然后，当我们到达柜台前，那位女士全神贯注于业务，计算着卷好的角币总额。我告诉她，“这个小家伙自己卷了镍币。”当女士处理完银币后，我开始从他的车里提那一袋便士。它们很重。我们将从镍币中得到40美元，从角币中得到27美元，从便士中得到103美元。
But the lady is pushing our pennies back out of the cage. "We cannot take pennies," she says. Ricardo, whom I've lifted up to see, gives one back to her. "We can't use these," she says. For a second, his face changes. Then, he is bawling. And he throws the roll of pennies at the lady's face. Her hand goes to the place above her eye. And she says, "I cannot help you."
但那个女士正把我们的便士推出窗口。“我们不能接收便士，”她说。里卡多，我把他抱起来让他看，还给她一个。“我们不能用这些，”她说。有一瞬间，他的脸变了。然后，他大哭起来。他把那一卷便士扔在女士脸上。她的手伸向眼睛上方的部位。她说，“我不能帮你。”
She has already given us the paper money for the other coins. She is looking at me with hate. I have seen real hate only a few times in my life. For a minute, I am only stuck. The shape of diamonds, it is shocking. But she is hurt above the eye, and I am not white.
她已经给了我们其他硬币的纸币。她带着仇恨看着我。我这辈子只见过几次真正的仇恨。有一分钟，我只是卡住了。钻石的形状，真令人震惊。但她眼睛上方受了伤，而且我不是白人。
Come on, Ricardo. I am fighting him into the wagon. I will pull all the rolls of pennies and him. We will make our getaway. He sees a garbage can, and he runs, dumping pennies in the open top. He is still crying. But he is mad now, also mad. I have to stop him. This is not right, our effort.
走吧，里卡多。我把他费力地拽进车里。我会拉着所有卷好的便士和他。我们将逃离这里。他看到了一个垃圾桶，他跑过去，把便士倒进开口顶部。他还在哭。但他现在也生气了，也很生气。我得阻止他。这不是正确的，我们的努力。
With him, what I do is almost tackle. Wanda's not a big person. I get on the floor and hold him until the fight is out.
对他，我做的是近乎扑倒的动作。万达不是个大个子。我扑到地板上把他按住，直到他不再挣扎。
Then, I tell him the story, still keeping him in my lap. "Once upon a time," I say, "I work in Beverly Hills, in a house that is very fancy, three layers, floors like a checkerboard, all marble. When I was first here, the lady, she opened the door and saw me. And right away, she said, 'You are hired.' She told me she knew like that, from the way I tie my sneakers.
然后，我给他讲故事，依然把他抱在膝盖上。“从前，”我说，“我在比佛利山庄工作，在一个非常豪华的房子里，三层楼，地板像棋盘，全是大理石。我刚到这时，那位女士，她打开门看到我。立刻，她说，‘你被雇用了。’她告诉我她就这样知道了，从我系运动鞋的方式。”
"The lady's husband, he had an office. And she wanted that to be neat, too. She hired me extra to go on the Saturday and straighten. He was there working while I cleaned. And he had one jar like this, up to my waist, full with pennies. And I asked him, did he want me to get tubes from the bank? And he said, 'You can take the pennies.' But I could not lift.
“那位女士的丈夫，他有个办公室。她也想让那里整洁。她额外雇我周六去整理。我打扫时他就在那工作。他有一个像这样的罐子，到我的腰那么高，装满了便士。我问他，要我从银行拿些管子吗？他说，‘你可以拿走这些便士。’但我提不动。”
And so I came back Sunday, my day off. And I sat on the floor out of his way and put all the pennies into tubes. He stepped around me when he went down the hall to use the restroom and the machines. He'd ask me how much money it was as he went by. And I'd tell him the total so far. "$36." "Good job, Wanda." The next time, it was $92. By the last time he passed, I was at $306. That time, his face looked strange, like two lines cross over it. He went down the hall, and I heard Xeroxing.
“所以我周日又回来，那天我休息。我坐在地板上，不碍他的事，把所有的便士装进管子里。当他去走廊上厕所或使用机器时，他绕过我。他经过时会问我那是多少钱。我会告诉他目前的总额。‘36美元。’‘干得好，万达。’下一次，是92美元。在他最后一次经过时，我已经存到306美元。那次，他的脸看起来很奇怪，像有两道线交叉在上面。他走进走廊，我听到了复印的声音。”
"On his way back, he stopped over me and said, "Maybe you'd better leave the pennies." "Whatever you like. It is up to you." When he was back in his office on the phone, I got up and left it all there-- the rolled pennies, the pile on the floor, the jar turned over. I took the bus to my sister, and I never went back to that house. That was the end of my career for a Beverly Hills nanny."
“在他回来时，他停在我上面说，‘也许你最好还是留下那些便士。’‘随你的便。由你决定。’当他回到办公室打电话时，我起身把所有东西都留在那儿——卷好的便士，地板上的堆叠，倒掉的罐子。我乘巴士去了我妹妹那里，再也没有回过那栋房子。那就是我比佛利山庄保姆生涯的终结。”
"Is that when you came to me?" "That is before. You were not yet born. But when the husband took the pennies I rolled to the bank, you know what they are telling him? They are telling him, too, what they are telling us. 'We cannot help you.' And you know what he will do then?"
“那是你来到我身边的时候吗？”“那是在那之前。你还没出生。但当那个丈夫把他让我卷好的便士带到银行时，你知道他们对他说什么吗？他们也对他说了对我们说的话。‘我们不能帮你。’你知道他后来会做什么吗？”
"He shouldn't have taken your pennies, Wanda. He is a bad man."
“他不该拿走你的便士，万达。他是个坏人。”
"A little bad. Listen. You know what he will do? He will throw the pennies in the garbage and walk away in a hurry. He is always in a hurry because he is rich. He is too busy, see?"
“有一点坏。听着。你知道他会做什么吗？他会把便士扔进垃圾桶，匆匆走掉。他总是很匆忙，因为他很有钱。他太忙了，明白吗？”
Now, I am fishing with my arm in the garbage, feeling among wet things for our tubes, the ones Ricardo threw. "But we will do something else. Come. You watch Wanda."
现在，我正把手臂伸进垃圾桶里摸索，在潮湿的东西里寻找我们的管子，就是里卡多扔掉的那些。“但我们会做点别的。过来。你看万达的。”
I pull him in the wagon out into the bright air. And we roll to the five-and-dime and the candy store. Each place, I count out the money in pennies. I put it in piles of 10 on the counter, so it is easy for the register clerk.
我拉着车子进入明亮的空气中。我们滚向五分十分店和糖果店。在每个地方，我用便士数出钱。我把它们在柜台上堆成10个一堆，这样方便收银员。
My father always said, "Spend your small money first." He remembered in the Philippines when money became toy. The smaller denominations, they would not buy anything. "And still, at that time," he told me, "There is so much wealth."
我父亲常说，“先花你的小钱。”他记得在菲律宾时，钱变成了玩具。小面额的钱，什么也买不到。“而且即便在那个时候，”他告诉我，“仍然有这么多的财富。”
Ricardo is in the wagon I am pulling, eating long orange and green candy worms. I tell him, "See? In the bank, it is nothing. But out here in the world, it is money. Not for the Philippines. But we can still buy, every day a little. It is our own private fund, our trust fund. I trust you, and you trust me. You have your candy. Now, let's use some pennies to buy Wanda her cup of coffee."
里卡多在我拉着的车里，吃着长长的橙色和绿色糖果虫。我告诉他，“看？在银行里，那什么都不是。但在外面的世界上，那就是钱。不是菲律宾的钱。但我们依然可以买，每天买一点。这是我们自己的私房基金，我们的信托基金。我信任你，你信任我。你吃你的糖果。现在，让我们用一些便士给万达买杯咖啡。”
Mona Simson, reading from her forthcoming novel, My Hollywood .
莫娜·辛普森，朗读她即将出版的小说《我的好莱坞》。
Well, the program was produced today by Susan Burton and myself with Alex Blumberg, Blue Chevigny, and Julie Snyder. Contributing editors, Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, Alix Spiegel, Nancy Updike, and consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Erik Halverston.
好了，节目今天由苏珊·伯顿和我本人制作，亚历克斯·布卢姆伯格、布鲁·谢维尼和朱莉·斯奈德参与。特约编辑：保罗·塔夫、杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔、南希·厄普代克，以及顾问萨拉·沃威尔。托德·巴克曼和埃里克·哈尔弗斯顿提供制作帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
（致谢）
To buy a cassette of this program, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380. Or you can listen to most of our programs for absolutely free on the internet at our website, www.thislife.org. Don't forget about those maps there. Thanks to Elizabeth Meister, who runs the site. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
如需购买本节目的录音带，请致电我们在芝加哥的WBEZ，电话312-832-3380。或者您可以在我们的网站www.thislife.org免费收听我们大多数的节目。别忘了那些地图。感谢运营该网站的伊丽莎白·迈斯特。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
（资助鸣谢）
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who somehow thinks that I owe him money.
WBEZ管理监督：托里·马拉蒂亚，他不知怎么地认为我欠他钱。
You're going to give me my check. You're going to give me my check.
你要把我的支票给我。你要把我的支票给我。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。